we're going to sign today that I've
always wanted to do and never got a
chance to do at school that's to make a
crystal garden and this is something
where you take a load of different metal
sorts and by putting it in the right
solution you can get these crystals to
grow and you can get something that look
well is essentially inorganic and turn
it into something that looks as if it's
organic like a plant chemical gardens or
something that many people make as
children I've never made been able to
get one to work so I'm quite envious
when my colleagues and make such a
beautiful one but the way it works or
the chemistry behind it is relatively
simple yeah we've got a lot of liquid in
here this is sodium silicate and water
so it's a 50/50 mix of the two so we've
got all just over three liters of liquid
we're going to try and pour this in here
without getting everywhere it's based on
the solution of sodium silicate some
people used to call it isin glass in the
old days people used it to preserve eggs
you put your egg in and it covered the
eggshell and stopped the oxygen getting
in why would you want to preserve an a
so you can keep it a long time without
it going bad oh and you'd still eat the
egg you'll still need the egg afterwards
let me get rid of this ideally we want
big lumps of our metal salts so we're
quite fortunate this is manganese
chloride and we've got a nice big lump
here if I can get out not breaking it
there we are okay and this is going to
get dropped in and we'll see where it
lands and we'll see what happens and it
goes leave that going
well I think one of the reasons that
people like them is because they're
interesting experiments that last quite
a long time you can put them on the
windowsill and if you have a large
container they will go on growing for
hours if not days whereas most chemical
reactions there's a bang or flash and
it's over okay unfortunately I got huge
lumps of this this is nickel nickel
nitrate so just pop that in and just see
what happens so already it's starting to
sprout these tendrils it looks really
like some kind of alien life-form now
and I'll put some more in in a bit I'll
just show you what the other sorts are
that I've got next one I've got a really
pretty color this is cobalt and I'll
grab as big a chunk as I can oh yeah
oh this was not so easy to put in
because it's quite liquid it's a cop
it's a copper salt this one so pop that
in in a chemical garden you have a
container of sodium silicate and you put
crystals of transition metal because
it's nice and colored at the bottom the
transition metal reacts to form a sort
of gooey layer of silicate the copper or
chromium silicate and this silicate is
filled with a liquid that is slightly
less dense than the solution because
you've precipitated out the silicate so
there's it's closer to pure water so it
tends to rise and as it rises more and
more solution comes out at the top and
so it gradually grows in like a thin
tube and as it goes up it gradually
thickens the walls so it becomes
stronger and stronger so it will go up
and up without collapsing and if you get
the colors right it can look really
quite like a garden
right then the next one we do have big
lumps of and this one is calcium
chloride so let's grab a chunk of that
so a bit like an egg shape there let's
put in that bit see if anything happens
with that okay the final thing we've got
is iron chloride but this as you can see
in the container is really granular so
it's not lumpy there's one lump and I'm
going to try and drop this in without it
scattering everywhere think about there
oh I think another one or two lumps of
COBOL and then we seeded our garden so
leave it for some time and see what
happens because the solution rising
depends on gravity that some things are
less dense than others there have been
several attempts to try and grow crystal
gardens in space particularly on the
space shuttle because there there is
zero gravity so what will happen my
friend David Jones devised a very
elegant apparatus where he could grow
for chemical Gardens in a piece of
apparatus that weights less than five
kilos so that's not much more than a
heavy book and of course everything on
the space shuttle has to be
fantastically safe you don't want
chemicals swimming around and hitting
the astronauts in the face and he did a
number of experiments or rather he set
up some experiments which the astronauts
did and they were quite surprising
because they didn't behave very
reproducibly some of it he published
quite a serious scientific paper here
and what was really interesting was the
weird shapes that he got and the first
few gardens he's got nice photos in here
the first few gardens were bit boring
he got these rather
fat tubes coming out in the next garden
it is cobalt garden he got something
that looked really quite exciting looks
like some weird organ that you've taken
from some sort of creature and my
favorite one was the one that he grew
from the next page here in a magnesium
nickel garden where it looks really
weird it was not clear exactly what was
determining these but David's idea was
it's probably the difference in
interfacial tensions the surface forces
between the growing silicate film and
the main solution which determine things
but although these look quite big if you
actually look at this picture of them
growing in space they're quite small
only fraction of a centimeter across I
shall never forget the site the vessel
of crystallization was three-quarters
full of slightly muddy water that is
dilute water glass from the sandy bottom
there strove upwards a grotesque little
landscape of various recovered colored
growths a confused vegetation of blue
green and brown sheets which reminded
one of algae mushrooms attached polyps
also moss then mussels fruit pods little
trees or twigs from trees here and there
of limbs it was the most remarkable
sight I ever saw and remarkable not so
much for its appearance strange and
amazing though that was as on account of
its profoundly melancholy nature for
when father lever kun asked us what we
thought of it and we timidly answered
him that they might be plants no he
replied they are not they only act that
way but do not think the less of them
precisely because they do because they
try as hard as they can they are worthy
of all respect that was Thomas Mann's
book dr. Faustus so he was actually
describing the Crystal Garden so I
thought it was quite a nice thing to
write about something so chemical